a real life story where she's she's
married she's successful she's like I'm
actually not happy I'm actually not like
that's like the circle back with that
lady yeah
and it's like there are there are people
who sometimes wake up and go [ __ ] I'm
not happy and I should be happy I hate
the concept of should and so I'm I'm a
really big advocate for like difference
do you think happiness like comes and
goes oh yeah like like do you think you
should just leave a relation a
relationship with like kids and stuff if
you're not happy so I was gonna I was
gonna say would you here's a question
would you sacrifice happiness for
fulfillment
yeah
would you because I think happened like
you say happiness can go up and down
yeah like it's an emotion right it comes
it's not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled with
what you have but would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
then it depends like for me happiness
it's
probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent on my fulfillment but I'm
always over there like we could die
tomorrow and if you're not happy and if
you're not like content if you're not if
you're not a whole individual
than anything else that you like put
yourself into like
oh it's a really tough that's it nothing
is ever back that's it going back to
nothing is black and white right or
wrong Better or Worse
um nothing's right or wrong but like
it's that gray area of like in some
situations I'd probably be like I'll
sacrifice happiness like even when you
study or you do a job if you do a job
interesting I think if you ask men the
same question most of them would say yes
I think women care a lot more about
being happy and Men care a lot more
about being fulfilled well that's like
because I think I think it's not about
like you especially if you have a family
it's not about you anymore like doesn't
she leave does she leave a husband and
kids and Eat Pray Love uh she leaves her
husband
a husband and a job yeah like I don't
know I think that's that's a bit selfish
you're leaving a commitment you made for
what to go like go to India but to be
selfish means that we're prioritizing
what everyone else wants compared to
what we want yeah but sometimes what you
want isn't right like emotions come and
go people leave like that's it right and
wrong very subjective that's it's all
about that gray area walking the middle
path right and wrong to one person so
that's it genocide and racism to one
person is right uh-huh like
things to one person are correct and you
could argue into your blue in the face
and be like that's not correct and they
literally be like like that's it Hitler
Hitler literally what is she it's it's
not even right I think there's
consequences and I I'd really like to
Circle back with that later yeah maybe
she made a book she made a lot of money
it might have worked out yeah yeah yeah
so you know what I mean maybe she did
but I don't think the average woman that
makes that decision it's gonna end up
well for her no no and that's why you've
got to be cognizant of differences and
privileges yeah uh circumstances and
things like that so yeah the average
woman could not be like I'm not happy in
my job or my marriage or being a mum
yeah because then you're like well [ __ ]
finances your your marriage your family
like your kids and the average woman
could not do that
um but it doesn't mean that she
shouldn't want to or she like it's just
like oh but then you get stuck
being like are you living for yourself
or are you living for others are you
living for expectations I think it's
okay to live for others and I'll give
you an example okay yeah I live a lot
for my dad's approval like a lot I care
a lot what my dad thinks like a lot and
I do a lot of things not because I want
to but because he wants me to and I
don't mean like like I would I'm doing
this clearly because I love this yeah he
doesn't care about social media but just
in terms of like like my last boyfriend
my dad didn't like and that really
bothered me it bothered me a lot because
I love my dad and I think like there's
some things it's okay it's almost a good
thing to like put you know values and
like your commitments and like your word
above what makes you happy at the time
yeah I I was gonna say I think the
difference between people to them people
back in the day is that we back in the
day people were all about Community yeah
it was all about doing what's best for
the community it was all about doing
what's best for your family whereas now
I think
I think back then we didn't have enough
individualism that people were
sacrificing a lot of their happiness for
their Community but now we've gone the
other way where there's so much
individualism now yeah that people are
no longer contributing or even care
about their local community or their
family and their nuclear family which is
why people leave
etc etc so I I agree and you know I'm my
family Nigerian and in our culture like
once you have kids it's about them you
do what's best for them so if you but
you staying with your partner is what's
best for the kids and you can make that
work that's what you do until they leave
then you split up or whatever actually I
always say people always ask me if I'd
stay with the cheater and I always say
no unless there were kids
hmm interesting why do you say that
because if they're kids it's not about
me
how about you if it I would
um I mean I've I've stayed with Jesus
I've stayed with Jesus and I know a lot
of that is actually based upon my
self-worth and being like you know XYZ
and I'd love to say no I know I deserve
better and I don't know but yeah if
there's kids it's a whole different
Ballpark and if you're it depends on how
selfish yourself because being selfish
isn't a bad thing because if you're like
when I'm living for others then when do
you live for you because
and it oh it really depends on like so a
lot of people love honor and pride we
don't think being selfish is a bad thing
so no no so you say you live for your
dad's approval my dad's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah that's a piece of [ __ ] my family we
are not close at all my mum actually had
been like me like right and so I'm like
if I'm not living for me and during my
life I could be dead tomorrow and if I
knew that I lived for everyone else I'm
living for their approval or my
well-being and my quality of life is
dependent upon how they feel towards me
yeah and if that's it it's not black and
white it's very much like
the people I love know that I love them
the people I love I'm I'm very much a I
want you to feel loved I want you but
then I'm like
I've done a lot of therapy and so
they're like hey Amy you could only feel
good about yourself when you think
others feel good about you and they're
like that's really
so your self-worth is dependent upon the
approval of others I think that's normal
well if everyone hates you there's
probably a reason well
as far as I'm aware no one's ever hated
me but I've been so I stayed with a
cheater because yeah I've stayed with
many cheaters and I I've been in a
relationship that it was the most toxic
thing that I've ever imagined that
everyone in my life is like we don't he
still talks to me and I still haven't we
broke up three four years ago we still
have an open communication path because
I can't block people because I'm like I
feel really bad if I block them even if
they're toxic for me and they're worse I
can't [ __ ] them I can't I can't do it
that's it I can't do it and everyone is
like Amy like are you are you confused
this person was awful to you
disrespected you and you still feel the
need to be good for them good for their
approval and I'm just like ah because it
makes you feel like bad person I bought
people like so so growing okay so going
back to the next next topic tonight okay
we're gonna talk about women getting
pregnant I made it first going okay so I
I'm gonna give you my opinion and I you
can comment on it I think it's 99.999
the woman's fault if she gets pregnant
why do you think that because we are in
control of sex
we won there's a million forms of birth
control as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible